- Your kid, what did
you do today at school?
Nothing.
- Nothing.
- How was it?
Fine.
- Fine.
- You always hear that, but
if parents can be intentional
about how they talk to
their kids after school.
I always ask, my kids and
I we have a running thing
so every day after school I
say, best, worst and weirdest,
and so they have to tell
me their best thing,
their worst thing, and
their weirdest thing.
Which it ends up with
a lot of funny stories,
but it also gives us an
opportunity to kind of dive into,
okay, so something didn't go very well.
Why not?
What was the catalyst
for that not going well?
Or if something went great,
what kind of strategies did
you use to pull that off?
I mean, how did you prepare?
How did you study?
How did you handle that tricky situation
on the playground or whatever.
But talking to your kids
instead of just, you know,
good job, A on the test.
Ask them, like, how did
you prepare for this?
What kind of learning went into this?
Likewise, if they didn't do so well.
Let's talk about what happened.
So, really helping parents
build that communication
with their kids about
strategies for learning.
And what works and what doesn't.
Having them draw the link between effort
and achievement is really important
so that kids are hearing
it everywhere they go.
- Very good.
Best, worst, weirdest.
I love that.
Super cool. (giggles)
Annie.
I'm sorry, Sam.
- It's alright.
I think the bottom line to
when it comes to parents
is they are sending us the
most precious gift they have.
There is nothing worse of a feeling,
than being a parent and
seeing your child struggle
in reading or struggle in math
and you want so badly to fix it for them
but you don't know how.
And so sometimes when
these parents come to us
and they're frustrated and
they just want it fixed.
They're coming from a place of love.
We have to train them too,
because they'll come upset.
My child is not a good reader
or my child's not good in math.
Well, now and yet.
- Right.
- So what are we gonna do?
There really isn't...
If you really want to
see the kids just go far.
A strong partnership between the kiddo,
the teacher, and the parent.
You've got a big support
system there to really hold up.
Then it comes down to what
Annie was talking about earlier.
Alright, we've got our
support system holding you,
now let's go for some effort.
- Right, right.
Exactly.
That sounds like a really strong
kind of foundation when you have that.
That sounds beautiful.
We have a question from Alyssa B.
How would you recommend
facilitating and encouraging
other faculty to promote growth mindset?
So this is a good question of what you do
kind of in your actual school environment?
- I think being transparent
and being vulnerable.
Teachers work really hard
and we do not have a
lot of time in the day.
It's sometimes, it's really
easy to hear something
and think that's just another thing.
So I think, by being transparent
and allowing people to
come into your classroom
or see the fruits of your kid's labor.
Let your kids lead things.
Let your kids be the ones who
go out and talk about things.
That's where the power lies
and that's where you show
that these mountains are being moved.
And then I think also being vulnerable,
being able to go to a meeting and say,
guys, I'm really working on growth mindset
but I really feel like I,
personally, am failing here.
I need some help.
And having those open discussions,
I think, encourage more people.
You know, we talk about
our students feeling safe
but it's the same thing with the staff.
The teachers, we've got to feel safe too.
To kind of embark on this,
because it's uncomfortable
at the beginning,
and it's a new way of
thinking and speaking.
There's a big power shift from
the teacher to the kiddos.
That's nerve wracking at the beginning.
It's such a positive power shift,
but scared to take at the beginning.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Getting administrators in on it too.
I really believe it.
Just like people approach things
with a growth and fix
mindset that a school has a,
organizations have a
growth or fixed mindset,
A lot of times you don't
have to look further
than the handbook to figure
out what are we valuing here?
Are we valuing growth?
Are we valuing perfection?
Getting a good gauge on what
is being valued and how.
Are only the kids who are
getting on the A honor roll,
are they the ones that
are being celebrated?
Do we have ways of celebrating
kids who are making less,
or making incremental steps toward growth?
Do we celebrate that
at all in our culture?
And so, as a teacher, I
think you have a opportunity
to speak to your admins and say,
we need to refocus and celebrate.
And, like Dave said, this is evidence.
This is research-based.
There is a strong body
of research going back,
what, 30 or 40 years?
- [Dave] Yeah, about that.
- That supports this as a
valuable learning intervention.
Just sharing that and being, you know,
being an advocate for it in your school.
I think, is key to changing
the culture of the entire school.
- Right.
Very good.
- Yeah, the only thing I would
add is just when I've talked
to teachers who have kind of catalyzed
these kind of cultural
transformations at their schools,
I think a lot of the
time it's really happened
with just a handful of teachers
who really started doing it
and they really started modeling it.
And going and talking to
other teachers about it.
It just took some time.
It wasn't like a we're all gonna do
growth mindset all at once.
I think in my experience,
that usually doesn't work very well.
It's usually more that you kind of
start around this kind of core
crystal group of teachers.
Then it kind of branches off from there.
And as other teachers can see the kind of
amazing things that can happen.
Then they start to say,
hey, maybe that could work in my class.
Actually, I'd like to have my kids
be that inspired or that motivated.
- That's interesting.
That's very interesting.
Actually, I'm very curious to know,
for Sam what made you want to try out
these growth mindset activities?
What was the catalyst for that?
- It actually stemmed, in
the beginning, it was...
I noticed that my kiddos
were coming without tools.
At the time I was in fifth grade,
and I had to send my babies
off to middle school.
I wanted them as empowered
and with as many strategies
as they could possibly
have before they went.
Because middle school can
be really difficult years.
And so I started looking at
things like their perseverance,
how do they speak to one
another, how do they advocate
for themselves when they need something?
We started little by little
looking at things like that.
I started really, kind
of, trying to research
and find things to support that.
It's funny, you know, we watch...
At the beginning of the
year I show my kids a video
of a really famous quantum theorist,
who he's melded science and
math and he's been working
on the same equation now for 12 years.
I promised my kids, I
will never make you work
on an equation for 12 years.
(all laughing)
But if he can do 12 years
we can do 20 minutes.
(all laughing)
We started trying to build that stamina.
Then it just kind of grew from there
and it was kind of the perfect timing.
Annie's book came out, Carol
Dweck's book is coming out.
PERTS is really on the stage now.
LearnStorm's out.
It feels like a lot of
us were seeking this.
If you look at the manifestation
of what is really come to the surface.
I think a lot of teachers,
at the same time,
really were feeling the same need.
- Right.
That's beautiful.
Alright.
I'm glad we can help fill that need.
That makes me feel good.
Leigh Ann Morgan from Ontario asks,
are there words and
phrases that foster growth
that I can include in my
student conversations?
I think, actually, all of you
have touched upon this idea of vocabulary.
Let's see if we can try to touch on that.
- I'm a firm advocate of the power of yet.
Anytime they say any kind of negative talk
I'll point to them, yet.
You know, and then they have to say it.
And then we're big on, alright, now what?
Or, great, what do you need?
We practice a lot at the beginning
of the year building a tool kit of, okay.
I'm stuck now, so what?
Alright, I can ask for more time.
I can ask to hear it in a different way.
I can ask the teacher to rephrase it.
I can ask, we talk about
what are the different things
I can do to advocate for myself.
Because, I might not always be
within these four walls
when I encounter a problem
and I need to have those intrinsic skills.
And so having that vocabulary
ready for your kids
and then on the teachers part,
really try and back away
from, good job, that's right.
Or, leave it to the class.
Mathematicians, what do you think?
This mathematician has proposed this idea.
Thoughts?
At the beginning, they
just stare at you like,
is it right or wrong?
You know.
But they start to learn
and it's so powerful.
And it is so hard as a teacher though,
when somebody throws something
wildly incorrect out there.
But the cool thing is, there's
a lot of grace in that too.
Because when the kids start
debating it and discussing it,
we talk about, do you have
the right to change your mind?
And the kid will say, oh,
I'd like to change my answer.
I think there's so much
power in how kids speak
to each other and speak to themselves.
It's hard for the teacher,
but kind of backing up and just
giving those launch points,
those launching questions.
Then your crowd control at that point.
- [Interviewer] Right, very good.
- I think just being mindful
of person praise versus process praise.
If we say to a kid who does really well,
oh, you're so smart.
They equate doing well with being smart.
That it's some inherent,
inborn thing that they have,
that they can do well.
And then when inevitably
they hit a setback.
Which they will.
And they don't do so well.
Then all of a sudden, it's like a question
of if I'm not smart then who am I?
So, just being mindful of praising effort
and the process that they took to learn.
Like, that was a really
great strategy you used.
Or, I like how you solved that problem.
Or if they breeze through something,
maybe that wasn't challenging enough.
Let's try to find something else.
So be mindful of that.
Being more robust with your feedback.
I think we like to use stickers
and say good job a lot.
In the book I wrote we call it,
well, I read it somewhere else,
but they call it Paula-praise.
So like on American Idol.
If you think back to American Idol,
the first with Simon,
and Paula, and Randy.
Paula would always say good job.
She didn't have any...
And Simon was a lot meaner,
but he was much more specific.
You don't want to be like that, but.
Definitely be specific in the
feedback that you're giving.
I would rather have less
feedback that's more specific
than generalized praise
that is really meaningless.
So, you want to be mindful of that.
Yeah, just thinking
about that I used to say,
c'mon you can do this, it's so easy.
That was something I said as a teacher.
And I look back and think,
oh my gosh, you know what,
that wasn't easy for that person.
It was easy for me, or
I thought it was easy.
But it wasn't easy for that person
and so what I was saying
was actually not helping.
It was counterproductive.
I thought I was being helpful.
Just really be mindful
of what you're saying
and how that affects the student
that you're working with.
Is really important.
- Yeah, I really love all those points.
I guess, just from a
growth mindset standpoint,
I think that the kinds of language we use,
the kinds of words we use
can be really important.
There are...
So for example, are you
referring to things as,
for example, we can talk
about building skills.
Really calling out when
you're doing something.
Like why are you doing it?
Oh, you're building your skills.
You're becoming a mathematician.
Or you're building your
writing skills right now,
you're becoming a better writer.
Really focusing students
on those processes.
How, the fact that they're
learning, while they're doing.
It's a kind of taking, again,
taking the focus off of the end result.
Really focusing it on the
thing that the students
can actually control for themselves.
Which is the process that their doing.
Reminding them and kind
of debriefing with them,
so that they really understand
what it is that they're doing.
And that all this effort
that they're doing
it's not just going into a grade,
it's going into them leveling up.
Them becoming a writer.
Them becoming a mathematician.
Or a scientist, or whatever that may be.
A great civic thinker.
- Right.
- Whatever that may be.
They're really developing those skills
and really making sure to call out
that learning is a process,
so they're enacting in your class.
- Right.
So, not just work for the sake of work,
but work for the sake of
growth and betterment.
I love that.
Alright.
So we're gonna wrap up.
I'm going to actually throw
you a bit of a curve ball
and ask you a final question,
but with a challenge.
What is one last piece of advice
for teachers for fostering growth mindset
that you would give this year,
if you can give it in 10 words or less.
Ho, ho.
I know.
Alright, I'm gonna start with Dave.
- Have a growth mindset about
building a growth mindset culture.
Was that too long?
- I think I did that right.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
- Alright, go ahead.
Annie, one last piece
of advice for teachers.
- I would say, model your
growth and fixed mindsets
and normalize mistakes in your classroom.
(giggles)
- Well done, well done.
- Thank you.
- I like it.
Alright, Sam.
Your last turn.
- Okay.
Be vulnerable, be a champion
for your kids and model.
- I love that.
That was very good.
And all very tweet-able.
Very great.
So I want to think Dave and Annie and Sam
for joining us today.
I learned something and I
hope that you all did, too.
I want to remind everyone
that there's still time to sign up,
so if you haven't signed
up, please, sign up.
Like right now.
Today.
But definitely by the end of October.
If you keep on tagging
your classroom celebrations
with #LearnStorm on Twitter and Facebook.
We really love seeing in the office,
so please keep on doing that.
Welcome back to the school year, teachers.
Thank you and good bye.